وقد قالت الاداره العسكريه للعاصمه
الاوكرانيه كيف ان شخصا قتل واصيب ثلاثه
اثر هجوم روسي واسع بالمسيرات على فجر
اليوم وقالت انه هو الثالث من نوعه خلال
24 ساعه واضافت الاداره ان قوه الدفاع
الجويه الاوكرانيه دمرت اكثر من 20 طائره
مسيره خلال الهجوم وصف رئيس الاداره
العسكريه في كييف الهجوم بانه هائل واقل
ان روسيا شلته باستخدام طائرات شاهد
ايرانيه الصنع فقط من جاده على ان عمده
كييف عن تعرض اربعه احياء على الاقل اضرار
جرامه وصفه بالهجوم الواسع الذي تعرضت له
المدينه مسفر عن اندلاع حرائق في منازل
وسيارات بعد تساقط حطام مسيرات عليها
كمن كيف مراسل جزيره حسان مسعود امس وفجر
اليوم كانت ايضا كييف مسرحا لهجمات عنيفه
بالمسيرات والدمار خلفك يخبرنا بالاثار
ولكن قبل ان نتحدث عن هذا هل هناك اي
معلومات حول ما اعلنته موسكو فيما يتعلق
بتعرض العاصمه اذا لهذه الهجمات بمسيره
ما يضع حتى هذه اللحظه لم تعلق السلطات
الاوكرانيه على الاحداث التي تشهدها موسكو
صباح هذا اليوم لكن ما يجري ربما في
العاصمه الاوكرانيه وهذه الهجمات
بالمسيرات لا يمكن فصلها عما يجري هناك او
على الاقل عن
ربطها بالتصريحات التي صدرت عن مسؤولين
اوكرانيين بشكل مباشر او غير مباشر قبل
يومين فقط عمده كييف كان قد قال ان انه
يوجه رساله الى القائد العام للقوات
المسلحه الاوكرانيه يقول له بشكل واضح
لماذا يعيش سكان كييف ما يعيشونه هنا ما
نشاهده هنا من هجمات بالمسيرات بشكل يومي
وبشكل مكثف اما سكان موسكو وفق قوله ووفق
تعبيره في بث تلفزيوني على التلفزيون
المحلي الاوكراني لا يعيشون ذلك وقال ان
على سكان موسكو ان يعيشوا ما يعيشه سكان
كييف وربما ان ربطنا هذا التصريح بما يحدث
هنا في كييف وما يحدث
في روسيا ربما نصل الى نتيجه معينه رغم
عدم وجود اي تصريحات رسميه بهذا الخصوص او
عدم وجود اي تبنن من الجانب الاوكراني
بهذا الخصوص ونحن وفق المتابعات خلال
الفتره الاخيره لا نتوقع ان نشهد تبني لما
يحدث في الداخل الروسي نظرا لان اوكرانيا
كانت تكرر مرارا في روايتها الرسميه وفي
تصريحات مسؤوليها ان اوكرانيا لن تقوم ولا
تقوم باي هجمات داخل الاراضي الروسيه انما
تقوم بالهجمات فقط على الاراضي التي
تعتبرها خاضعه للسيطره الاوكرانيه هذا
يذكر ايضا ياتي بعد يوما فقط هذه الهجمات
الاوكرانيه فيما يتعلق بالاس تهداف
للكرملين والذي نفت فيه كيف تماما ان تكون
لها اي صله بتلك الهجمات التي تمت روسيا
فيها كيف
بالضبط وهذا الامر وتعليقات المسؤولين
حينها جاءت ايضا في اطار ان ما يحدث في
روسيا هو عباره عن
احداث اضطرابات وفق قولهم داخليه وان ما
يجري هناك ربما قام به مواطنون روس
لديهم مشكله مع نظام الروسي الحالي وهم
استطاعوا ان يقوموا بشراء هذه المسيرات من
اي متجر وفق تعبيرهم ووفق قولهم هذا كان
التعليق الاوكراني الرسمي على لساني عدد
من المسؤولين عن هذه الاحداث لانهم دائما
ما ينفون اي صله للجانب الاوكراني بهذه
الاحداث
ويرمون الكره بملعب الجانب الروسي فقط
يقولون ان من يقوم بهذه الهجمات او حتى
الهجمات على المناطق الحدوديه في منطقه
على سبيل المثال هم مواطنون روس هم
مواطنون من الداخل الروسي وليس لا اي
علاقه بذلك ولكن الحدث اليوم ما جرى في
موسكو اتى بعد ساعات فقط على تصريح
للرئيس الاستخبارات العسكريه الاوكرانيه
كريلو بودانوف الذي كان قد حذر من ان من
يقوم بارهاب وفق قوله المواطنين
الاوكرانيين في اوكرانيا وهذا التصريح اتى
بعد ساعات على استهداف مركز حساس هنا في
العاصمه الاوكرانيه كيف حتى هذه اللحظه لم
تفصح السلطات الرسميه الاوكرانيه عنه قام
رئيس الاستخبارات الاوكرانيه بالتعليق
بقوله ان هؤلاء الذين يقومون بارهاب
المواطنين الاوكرانيين سيشعرون بالندم
قريبا وقريبا جدا وفق تعبيره وفي تصريحه
وهذا الامر معي ما حدث في موسكو بالمسيرات
وهي بنفس الشكل الذي تتعرض له العاصمه
الاوكرانيه منذ بدايه شهر مايو بشكل مكثف
غير مسبوق نحن اليوم في الثلاثين من مايو
وما حدث منذ بدايه شهر مايو هو ان كياف
تعرضت لسبعه عشر هجوما بالمسيرات
الانتحاريه بشكل يومي او بشكل شبهي وكل
يومين على الاقل وبوتيره متسارعه وخلال
الايام الثلاثه الاخيره كان هناك هجمات
مكثفه بشكل غير مسبوق اطلاقا منذ بدايه
الحرب بصواريخ وبمسيرات بشكل متزامن لكن
هذه الليله واسمحي لي ان اطلعك على حجم
الدمار في موقع واحد فقط من هذه
ضربات هنا وسط العاصمه الاوكرانيه نحن
امام هذا المبنى الذي سقط فيه قتيل واصيب
ثلاثه جرحى وتم اجلاء كل سكان المبنى كما
تشاهدون ربما السكان هنا مروا وهم تم
اجلائهم بشكل عاجل من هذا المبنى بعد
اصابته بم او كما تقول السلطات الاوكرانيه
وفق الروايه الرسميه وننسب ذلك لهم ان
حطام المسيره فقط هو الذي اصاب هذه هذا
المبنى ولكن ما ادى الى احداث ضرر كبير في
هذا المبنى وبالسيارات المحيطه
بكل المنطقه ايضا المجاوره والقريبه من
هذا المبنى تضررت وصابها الضرر بشكل بالغ
قبل قليل كان هناك وحدات من الصليب الاحمر
تقوم بنقل المواطنين من هنا وهذه احدى هذا
احدى المباني فقط الذي تعرض للخصف بشكل
كبير بشكل بالغ الاثر انما ايضا في ذات
الوقت فان عدد من المواقع فقد اصابها ايضا
الضرر بفعل هذه الهجمه المكثفه بالمسيره